Maybe YouTube just hates you guys enough
or yeah they don't pay attention so they
don't know what we're saying here cuz
I've seen people get their channels
taken down for less than what we do on
the weekly I know and it's probably one
of the beauties of being so Niche but
not too freaking popular right if you
have too many sponsors that own you
basically it's not like you got HMS who
are like hey you better be chill about
this topic we're laughing about like
some guy who got mangled in a
accident and hin is like hey you better
be careful that guy has a receding
hairline I know right we're trying to
sell lawn care service and then like
right after the ad read Bart Is
straddling Anthony and like humping him
from the back you know he's mock
his
face and that by the way actually
happened